a fully CG animated Adventure Garfield
gets a superstar voice cast with a
famous feline himself voiced by Chris
Pratt his fellow MCU star Samuel L
Jackson has come on board to provide the
pipes for Garfield's father Nicholas
Holt Bing Rams Bowen Yang cesal strong
Hannah wittingham and Brett goldsteen
are also lending their vocal talents to
the film behind the scenes it'll be DG
handling the animation a studio that
normally supplies First Rate CGI effects
for some of Hollywood's biggest
Blockbusters like fastex and Jurassic
world Dominion Disney screenwriter David
Reynolds meanwhile is crafting the
script with Chicken Little Helmer Mark
dindle directing after securing a
February release initially the film was
bumped to May 24th 2024 once again my
life has been saved by the miracle of
lasagna